three like-minded leaders forging closer
ties as they see growing threats common
to them all U.S President Joe Biden
wants to build on the marked improvement
in relations between Japan and South
Korea since coming to office Japanese
prime minister fumio kashida and his
South Korean counterpart Yun circular
have set a course to overcome
traditional differences so the bar is
set low really to improve relations and
I think Washington wants to sort of
institutionalize trilateral cooperation
and once a joint statement in which the
two countries commit themselves to
enhanced security cooperation all three
countries have been brought Closer by
the threat of North Korea's continued
weapons development
in order to fundamentally Block North
Korea's nuclear and missile threats the
Republic of Korea the United States and
Japan must closely cooperate on
reconnaissance assets and share data in
real time
the three have taken part in joint
military drills and embarked on
intelligence sharing raising alarms in
North Korea's only significant Ally
China is watching this trilateral
meeting intensely suspecting the U.S and
its Northeast Asian allies of trying to
restrain its Growing Power at a time
when beijing's friendship is being
eagerly sought by Moscow as it looks for
any support in its continuing war in
Ukraine this was Russian defense
minister Sergey shoigu on a recent visit
to North Korea which is allegedly
supplying Russia with Munitions followed
by the 70th anniversary celebration of
the ending of the Korean War also
attended by a high-profile delegation
from China of course it also goes in the
other direction you know the more that
the Beijing Moscow and and Pyongyang
cooperate with each other the more that
Seoul Washington and turkey are going to
cooperate each other as well the
shifting power blocks of the Asia
Pacific as neighbors seek security and
Advantage amid increasing insecurity Rob
McBride Al Jazeera Seoul